Boeing avait annoncé dès 2020 s'était
terminé pour son fameux 747 l'avion de
ligne de plus célèbre au monde le
dernier exemple là est sorti en décembre
de la ligne de montage et aujourd'hui
les milliers d'employés de Boeing se
rassemblés pour le livrer au dernier
client
dès son introduction Le cholesté
imaginaire des voyageurs il possède deux
ponts quatre turbos réacteurs et les
systèmes de navigation les plus
sophistiqués de l'aviation civile
c'était le début d'une époque où on
pouvait faire des avions beaucoup plus
puissants qui allaient beaucoup plus
loin et qui est transporté beaucoup plus
de passagers et c'était les premiers pas
pour essayer de démocratiser l'aviation
le 7 47 devient transporteur à tout
faire de sa génération on peut le
transformer en avion cargo en avion
présidentiel et on va même le modifier
pour participer à l'aventure spatiale
son problème il consomme beaucoup de
carburant et avec le temps les besoins
des compagnies d'aviation ont évolué
vers des modèles aussi performants mais
moins gourmands quand la philosophie de
voyage a changé on ne veut plus des
avions avec un réacteur transporter 400
50600 700 personnes même si on ça dépend
de configuration donc on veut plutôt
plusieurs avions de plus petite taille
depuis une cinquantaine d'années Boeing
a construit plus de 1500 exemplaires du
7,47 on estime que plus de 450 appareils
sont toujours en circulation mais qu'à
peine une cinquantaine d'entre eux
servent toujours aux transports de
passagers la majorité appartenant la
compagnie Lufthansa le dernier sac 47
servira lui aussi aux transports de
marchandises puis éventuellement le roi
des avions disparaîtra du ciel au grand
malheur de ses nombreux supporters
l'avion est magnifique avec les deux
ponts avec cette espèce de boss sur le
dos tout ça c'est fait de 747 quelque
chose de mythique qu'on a peu connu dans
l'histoire de l'aviation
ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal